you were watching ColdFusion TV hi
welcome to another ColdFusion video as
most of you know Tesla Justin vowed to
electric semi-trucks and a new
high-performance roadster in this video
I'll give my thoughts and commentary on
the event and what this means for Tesla
and the industry as a whole
first let's briefly take a look at the
trucks TRUCKING is actually a bigger
industry than you might imagine taking
the United States as an example the
trucking industry employs over 7 million
people per year and 80 percent of all
cargo in America is still transported by
trucks that's four times as much as air
pipeline rail and sea combined with this
in mind you can easily see how logistics
companies would be very interested in an
electric truck that performs better and
is much cheaper to run then it's diesel
counterpart Tesla shifted into high gear
unveiling its new all-electric
semi-truck joining us right now analysts
at arc invest it's hasha kini Tosha good
to see you good thanks so much for
joining us now at arc you cover
autonomous cars and innovative materials
what did you think of the big reveal
well Maria it confirmed what we had
thought which is that an easy semi is
going to be cheaper than a diesel semi
and by the way that truck is semi
autonomous today when that turns fully
autonomous we think the cost per
ton-mile could be reduced by 75% from
today's rates that's gonna be cheaper
than rail it's gonna drive more goods
over trucks and it's gonna completely
transform logistics as we know it
Wow the electric trucks will do 0 to 100
kilometers now or 60 miles an hour in
five seconds versus 15 seconds for the
average truck in a worst-case scenario
with a max gross vehicle weight of
80,000 pounds or about 36 tons the truck
will be able to get 500 miles of range
an electric truck is inherently easier
to drive because there's no gears but
meanwhile it's not uncommon for normal
trucks to have over 16 years Tesla
claims that 30 minutes of charge will
get you 400 miles and for reference to
fill the tank of a normal truck takes
about 15 minutes so either way this
makes sense if you've been driving a
long time and just need a break
auto pilot will be standard so if you
have a medical emergency while driving
the truck will keep to its lane
gradually stop and if it doesn't hear a
response from you it even calls an
ambulance the truck is also claimed to
be a lot safer one of the reasons is due
to a lower center of gravity from the
weight of the battery packs making
rollovers very unlikely the risk of the
truck jackknifing has also been said to
be virtually eliminated due to
independent torque vectoring on each
wheel the company is offering a 1
million mile guarantee on each of these
vehicles so although that's all pretty
cool and potentially revolutionary the
main story was the Tesla Roadster 2.0
the original RAZR was the car that
started Tesla back in 2008 The Electric
Forest had its share of obituaries over
the years but the new American car
company Tesla is determined to prove
that the concept is a workable one the
manufacturer has just launched the Tesla
Roadster an electric car that looks good
and can hold its own in the performance
arena so far Tesla is off to a promising
start Tesla has pre-sold about 900 cars
and it plans to build and sell over
3,000 more in 2009 and 2010 and in 2017
it was finally time for a refresh the
new updated model is an absolute beast
so as many of you know it can do 0 to
100 kilometres an hour or 60 miles an
hour in 1.9 seconds and it's the first
production car in the world to break the
two-second barrier and it can do zero to
160 kilometres an hour or a hundred
miles an hour in 4.2 seconds it's said
to also produce 10 kilonewton meters of
torque at the wheels at the recent
presentation musk didn't say the top
speed but did say that it was above 250
miles an hour or 400 kilometers now by
comparison the Agera RS by Sweden's
Coyne exec currently holds the world
record at 270 seven point nine miles an
hour or about 445 kilometers now the
crowd was still getting over the top
speed figures when musk announced at the
race they had a 200 kilowatt hour
battery which were provided 620 miles of
range or over a thousand kilometers for
comparison the P 100 D
has about 420 miles of range I think the
range will be key to converting or at
least convincing those at a critical of
electric cars that this is no longer a
gimmick and also for all of this it's
important to note that this is the base
model the slowest option of this new
Tesla Roadster so the question has to be
asked is this actually feasible or is
this pie in the sky or the website
Jalopnik spoke word Carnegie Mellon's
venkat Viswanathan mechanical
engineering assistant professor he
focuses on next-generation battery
technology he remarked that the 1.9
second figure actually seems reasonable
he added that a 200 kilowatt hour
battery pack can easily go 600 miles an
interesting point of note is he
estimates that the battery weight alone
will be 833 kilograms or 1,800 pounds as
it turns out it's actually the grip on
the tires and the management of getting
the power down from the motors to the
actual wheels that will be the main
bottlenecks in this vehicle but Tesla
has actually had a lot of experience
with the P 100 D on that front
so it seems reasonable that they could
get that done the thing that stood out
to me is that this car is breaking all
the records
it looks like Tesla is doing this to
make a solid point this vehicle was
meant to be a statement a kind of
watershed moment to tell people that
this is the direction that cars going to
take no one can argue with it if it's
faster quicker and more value for money
than most supercars that are out there
but that is if the production model has
the same numbers that are listed for the
prototype figures speaking of other
supercars he is a fun list of how the
Roadster 2.0 stacks up against the
petrel competition Nissen gt-r Nismo
version 0 to 60 in 2.7 seconds costing
you 175,000 McLaren p1 GTR 0 to 60 2.4
seconds at a cost of 3.6 million dollars
lamborghini aventador sv 0 to 60 2.4
seconds again cost four hundred ninety
three thousand bugatti chiron zero to
sixty two point three seconds cost 2.6
million
now this next one is interesting the
Dodge Challenger SRT demon coming out
next year 0 to 60 in 2.3 seconds
cost eighty four thousand dollars so
that's actually great value for money
next up the Porsche 918 Spyder zero to
sixty in two point two seconds cost
eight hundred forty five thousand and
then of course the new Tesla Roadster
zero to sixteen one point nine seconds
cost two hundred thousand so the
question must be asked are there any
cars that can actually do zero to sixty
in under two seconds right now the
answer is yes but they're all f1 cars
dragsters or rally cars but surprisingly
the acceleration of f1 cars average from
about 2.1 seconds 2.7 seconds for fun
nasa's saturn v rocket can do 0 to 60 in
1.5 seconds but if you learnt the
ultimate a top fuel dragster can do that
in 0.8 seconds it accelerates so quickly
that the car is already traveling at 60
miles an hour by the time the rear tires
have crossed the start line you've got
to keep in mind that these drag cars
can't even turn properly and need a
parachute to even slow down
this isn't to mention that that they can
only see one person and consume over
half a standard tank of fuel per run so
all in all 1.9 seconds by Tesla in a
production car isn't bad at all
and if the company can get this into
production by 2020 as planned
the world has no choice but to realize
that they're looking at the future but
all of that being said it's not all
roses for Tesla there's a wider context
at play that I should talk about some
analysts were saying that this new
roadster may have been a way to shift
investor attention away from the model 3
production issues and reignite some
excitement in the company and I got to
say that when I was watching the
announcement I hadn't sensed - such
excitement and elation from a crowd
since the Apple keynotes of old I'm not
so sure if the sole purpose of the
Roadster was to shift attention away
from the model 3 but I can certainly see
the announcement being rushed forward to
partly achieve that so anyway what
production issues am I talking about
with the model 3 as most of you know the
model 3 was supposed to be the electric
car that was for the masses
when it was launched back in July the
company was anticipating a production
rate of 20,000 cars per month by the end
of December in the last quarter though
Tesla only produced 260 model threes
earlier in November
Tesla pushed back its target volume
production on the model 3 by about 3
months to fix production bottlenecks
it's no secret that the fate of Tesla
largely hangs on the success of the
model 3 so it's important that they get
this right and with vehicles like the
electric semi truck and the new roadster
in the pipeline I really do want Tesla
to succeed so that these vehicles come
to fruition it would be a lot easier to
sit and criticize about how the company
is missing deadlines but I think it's
worth appreciating the magnitude of what
the company is actually trying to do
within the order industry it's not easy
for such a small and brand-new company
so hopefully the production issues get
sorted out and the rest flows smoothly
from there so anyway what do you guys
think
what's your views on the Tesla truck and
the new roadster let me know your
thoughts in the comments section below
anyway thanks for watching I know if
being away for a little while I've
actually been pretty sick I'm feeling
better now but I recently just got my
house broken into so that was another
thing to add to what was going on but
everything should be on track after this
week anyway thanks for watching I'll see
you guys soon for the next video this
has been - go go you've been watching
cold fusion cheers guys have a good one
[Applause]
thinking
[Music]
I think